hey guys Pete here are you ready for
some Game of Thrones Season eight
filming news and some spoilers if you're
trying to avoid production spoilers for
the final season of Game of Thrones then
this video will not be for you there's
nothing that's a dead giveaway here but
there is a lot that can be speculated on
which is pretty exciting
in my last Game of Thrones Season 8
video we looked at all the stuff that
had been going on up in Winterfell at
the set there and in that video I talked
about how they were moving on to Iceland
and how this stars had been seen there
not to much of anything came out as far
as filming shots or anything came from
the Iceland shooting but we knew that
they were going directly from there to
Croatia and they've arrived and at first
it was a bit quiet
we saw them setting up we saw photos of
the cast and crew the local news
organizations were reporting that Game
of Thrones were in town that they were
getting ready to film but nobody knew
who was there and there were all these
rumors that Kit Harington was gonna show
up but it didn't make sense to me that
he'd be in the King's Landing filming
section you know we expect to see the
Lannisters particularly Cersei now but
why would John be there is what I kept
thinking but after a little bit of stuff
leaked out today there were a ton of
photos of Kit Harington he is there he
is dressed in his northern attire and he
is shooting in Croatia there was a
couple different shots of him with
characters there's a guy with a black
hood who is nobody recognizable as far
as I can tell there's another similar
shot where he's with two guys in hoods
the best guess here is that these guys
are from the Nights Watch but they're
not it's not dollars head or anybody
that we've seen and really that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense either they're
wearing black that's why it seems like
it could be that they could just be
northern soldiers but again the whole
idea of him in King's Landing is a
little bit odd as far as the director
goes we know that David Nutter is there
and we know that he's directing episodes
1 2 & 4 so if John is there
seen that he shooting that we have to
figure that it's early in the season or
at the latest the fourth episode we take
what we know about spots Nik being three
and five and then of course the show
runners are directing the final episode
dan and Dave we could guess that there's
something big that happens in Episode
three and Miguel Zapata Nick's first
episode that causes John to go south the
only other thing if you go way out in
left field and say well you see that DB
Weiss is in one of these photos and
that's not uncommon I wouldn't think but
they could be shooting the final episode
I guess at the same time like they're
obviously only gonna be in Croatia for a
few days so they're going to do as much
as they can and really shoot everything
that needs to be shot in the exterior of
that location they won't be coming back
so yeah there's a lot to speculate about
here what is John doing there is that
that cold in the south that he needs to
wear those furs or is this just doubling
for somewhere else that's outdoors in
the north and we don't know the pictures
are pretty good these were came from the
newspapers and different people there we
did have a shot of a banner on one of
the sets
that's the Lannister banner so we know
that Cersei still in charge for some of
what they're shooting there so yeah I
mean it could be like like I said left
field guess it could be to show him
arriving after our everything said and
done and he's rolling in the King's
Landing to see what's left or to take
the seat or what I don't know you know
what I mean like I'd be loving to hear
what you guys think about this for sure
the other thing that we saw is that
they're getting done building the giant
set outside of Titanic Studios rumor has
it that this is a re-creation of King's
Landing and the reason they're building
it from the ground up outside of the
studio is so that they can burn it down
this has led to the speculation that the
Dragons will attack King's Landing we
don't know if it would be Daenerys as
dragons or the night
this could tie into why Jon's there of
course John may be riding ragle by that
period of time and him and Daenerys
might go down there and burn some things
but these are all faraway shots that you
can't really make much of but I am
pretty confident in the sources that
said that it was going to be an outdoor
King's Landing scene and it would
eventually get burnt down one other
thing fans were talking about and a few
of these shots that came from the
Croatian press there is a woman who
looks to have blonde hair like Daenerys
Emilia Clarke has dyed her hair and the
woman is wearing dark glasses but you
can't see a straight shot and she's not
performing she's just there on set so
some people thought that might be Emilia
Clarke but there's no way to tell for
sure could be anybody that works on the
set we also know that the mountain is
there he posted on Instagram shot of him
eating in Croatia so that's consistent
with Cersei being there but of course
she's there that's where she lives
Jon Snow is a lot bigger of a question
so let me know what you guys think in
the comments is John in King's Landing
or is this a set that's going to be used
somewhere for up in the north as Jon
Snow come with Daenerys as a conqueror
to destroy King's Landing and take
revenge on Cersei is he just there to
shoot the breeze and ask her what's
going on after he started riding regal
and travels freely across this giant
land of Westeros nothing really makes a
great sense but if they were shooting
the last episode I guess that could make
sense but I haven't read anything to
indicate that so that's just pure
speculation please like the video if you
enjoyed it make sure you subscribe to my
channel and set notifications I'll be
doing Game of Thrones Season 8 videos as
soon as stuff comes out I'm also working
on Westworld even though we got a couple
of months to wait so if you're into that
show things are looking really good
check out the Easter eggs video I just
made because there's some cool stuff to
speculate there that's it for now thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon